a mysterious and rare condition
transmitted by ticks maybe on the rise a
bite from the aggressive Lone Star tick
can cause people to develop a red meat
allergy and in some cases a reaction to
dairy products a researcher from the
University of North Carolina Chapel Hill
discovered more than 5000 cases were
reported in the country that is up from
3500 two years ago the Lone Star tick is
found in much of the eastern US but it
is most common in the South some reports
show the ticks are spreading to new
areas as temperatures climb our dr.
taryn Rula is here with the news good
morning doc and not good news and not
good news how does it work that a tick
can cause something like a meat allergy
sounds crazy yeah so this is really an
emerging a Lurie allergy that we've just
begun to characterize in the last 10
years so much so that we don't really
track cases with the CDC but essentially
the meat allergy is an allergy to a
sugar or carbohydrate that's found in
animals that are non primates so the
cells and tissues of cows pigs sheep
they carry this it's called alpha
galactose carbohydrate we don't so when
the tick bites those wild animals and
then bites us the theory is that it's
injecting us essentially in entering
into our bloodstream is this sugar that
we are not used to our body mouths in a
antibody response and then when we eat
meat we in some people who are
sensitized they can have an allergic
reaction is it permanent if you get it
so it in some cases it could be but in
most cases we think that it can
dissipate over time usually within a
couple years but if you get another year
right years three years Wow
but if you get tick bites again then
it's gonna make it longer for the
condition to go away are the symptoms of
a lone Star tick bite I love how you say
it's named after my home and sorry I'm
not proud of this time around so in when
in the meat allergy we're talking about
a skin rash hives gastrointestinal
symptoms so cramps nausea vomiting
diarrhea you can also have asthma or
even anaphylaxis so you can treat it
with antihistamines steroids people who
have severe reactions should carry an
EpiPen but as I mentioned no real
treatment or cure other than avoiding
red meat the Lonestar ticks look
different than other ticks have a small
cowboy hats
[Laughter]
they have a white spot the females do on
their Brown back the males have kind of
white streaks or spots around the
outside but that's very imperceptible
right you're not gonna tell what the
naked eye I think that you you would
have to really look very very closely
but the important thing is to do tick
checks when you come in from being
outdoors take a shower you can wash your
clothes in the door put them in the
dryer for 10 minutes on high heat that
will kill the ticks avoid kind of those
high grassy areas stay on the trails so
there's things you can do treat your
dogs for ticks that could help the
summer warming environment global
climate change all of these things are
contributing to an increase in parasites
like ticks we're also talking about
mosquitoes it is really Ito season upon
us yes what should we be doing generally
to protect ourselves well so one of the
things that people think about for
instance is West Nile virus and so at or
Zika we talked about before important
things removing standing water again
using EPA repellents you can also treat
your gear with permethrin using screens
staying indoors air conditioning so you
know there are things you can do but
unfortunately for things like West Nile
for example in most cases there aren't
symptoms one out of five people will get
things like fever rash headache joint
pain muscle aches and then one out of
150 can develop more severe cases like
encephalitis or meningitis which is
inflammation of the brain or seriously
very pesky insects messing water so
there are thanks